before the video starts want to give a
huge shout out to food not sure of the
type renounce it but that's how I'm
going to pronounce it food too not sure
but he gave me one mill to give away so
we're going to be giving away 1.5 mill
thanks to him so huge shout out to him
and let's get started into the video
[Music]
[Applause]
alright guys it's time to pick the
random winner for the 1.5 mil giveaway
again shout out to suit and all I have
to do is paste the youtube link in here
click enter
randomly pick winner
and the winner is frog list so username
j-money for life so he is the winner so
I will find a minigame I'll make sure he
liked this video and subscribed and then
I will give him the money okay let's go
start it into real video what is up guys
today I'm showing you what i got from a
hundred barrows chest and i'm going to
start off by showing you the loot that i
got that was just runes and
miscellaneous items and then i'm be
showing you the Barrows pieces i got and
then at the end of them do some
calculations for you guys let's get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
damn son whered you buying this
[Music]
[Applause]
with
[Music]
I finally finished 100 barrels chest and
I was super excited I didn't get a clip
of every single thing I got but I did
write down everything so the numbers are
right and now it's time to show you guys
the items I got
Oh
[Music]
these are some clips of me so in my
barracks Brossard because at the time I
noticed that the prices had gone way up
the normally selling from 200k and layer
sulfur it's sold for 450 K basically
let's just shine proof that I sold for
corn 50 K now it is time to do some
calculations so for my runes total I had
five thousand two hundred forty nine
death runes 9345 chaos runes 3498 blood
rooms and nineteen thousand 654 mind
runes for my boat slash miscellaneous I
had 2718 bolts for my loop half key I
had one for my tooth half K I had two
and elite clue Scrolls I did not get a
clip of it but I do have it I have one
and for my barrows pieces I got one
taurog plate legs one taurog plate body
one taurog hammers one varrock
Broussard's one Buraq plate skirt -
Carol skirts and one guffin war spear
now we will do some numbers so for the
death runes the total GP of the
deference I got was 1 million five
hundred eleven thousand seven hundred
twelve Catherine's nine hundred sixty
two thousand five hundred thirty-five
blood runes eighty eight hundred seventy
six thousand five hundred four minor in
fifty eight thousand nine hundred sixty
two for a total of three million four
hundred 9713 for the bolt slash
miscellaneous for the bolt it was one
hundred seventy six thousand six hundred
seventy loop half eight thousand nine
hundred 3 2013 4 thousand eight hundred
sixty two an elite scroll I can't sell
it obviously and the totals for that was
two hundred twenty thousand four hundred
thirty five and for the Barrows pieces
the taurog plate legs 287,000 trying to
play buddy 247,000 to our cameras one
hundred thousand barack Brossard 450,000
barack plate skirt one nine three
hundred fifty nine thousand Carol skirt
both of them combined is 410-thousand
Guffin war sphere 2 million eighty
thousand at the time that I got the
guttin war spirit was worth three
million so
just keep in mind sometimes it
fluctuates and the total of that was
four million nine hundred thirty three
thousand and so the grand total of
everything with the runes both less
miscellaneous the pieces oh and the
coins 77377 coins total for a grand
total of eight million six hundred forty
thousand five hundred twenty five and
that's not counting supplies and for the
calculations you're supposed to be have
a 1 in 16 chance of getting a Burroughs
item which is point zero six two five
and the result I got I got 8 out of 100
chests which is 0.8 and then the eight
million six hundred forty thousand five
hundred twenty-five that I made divided
by the hundreds chest
equals eighty six thousand four hundred
five per chest and then the total number
that I made divided by ten that's the
amount of hours it takes it took me
around an hour to get ten chests if I
did it well and that would be eight
hundred sixty four thousand 552 per hour
so that's how much money you could make
and I just used average gear and that's
not counting supplies alright guys
thanks for watching and stay tuned for
the next video
[Music]